[Music]
so this week we are filming a short
called lightsabers for men i was
arrested at disneyland it's also an
excuse to do like 20 different silly
lightsaber effects so josh myself and
matt are gonna be sitting down and
spending this week cranking on
lightsabers and trying to make them look
cool the lightsabers have been around
for a long time and there's a lot of
different ways to do lightsabers so
first things first i want to talk to you
a little bit about lightsaber history
so gentlemen i want to talk to you a
little bit about lightsabers
specifically lightsaber history star
wars has been around since the 1970s
which puts it at about 43 years old or
so 44.
like i don't remember much of star wars
the only time i've watched star wars was
when i was 12 years old and i haven't
watched it since i i didn't think they
were that great to be honest
but lightsabers have been around for a
long time and there's a lot of different
ways to do lightsabers so first things
first let's take a look at the original
a new hope with the very first shot of
the lightsaber and i want to hear your
guys's take on how you think they did it
was a blast
how do you think they did it first you
got to get the crystal
uh i could see the hidden cut and like
this lightsaber comes out you can see
the cut there but how they actually did
it i'm not 100 sure i know that there's
a cut here so i know that something had
to be replaced because there would be no
use for a jump cut unless there was some
sort of swap of the lightsaber right for
the effect there's some bar of light
possibly like a retro reflective thing
matt you got it right the very first
star wars the way they did it was they
had a rod with a retro reflective
material on it basically the same thing
you'd see in like safety vests that are
on like street signs so now it's spin
and when that spin it gives you like the
warble and the flicker and that kind of
stuff the thing about retro reflective
materials it's only going to reflect
light if the light is right by your eyes
or your camera lens so they had to have
lights blasting from right next to the
camera lens whoa oh
look at that
non-reflective
ears reflected yeah and so you're saying
that all this is practical though well
here's the thing we it's hard to see the
original lightsabers these days the
original star wars has been like erased
from the internet in the world there's
like six versions of the original star
wars they're all a little different the
spinning retro reflective material they
got rid of that so what was the next
thing how do you think they did the next
set of light sabers and empire strikes
back
at this point it would be like i don't
know are we are we talking something
where it's like they're they're actually
painting on film on the film now they
are doing rotoscope they are doing
rotoscopes so they literally had an
artist go in there project them frame by
frame and then paint where the
lightsabers were with like black paint
and you can do a mask with that that
they're then using to shine light
through onto the film giving you actual
exposed film as if somebody was actually
shining a light there and giving you
actual glow that's costing the light
passing through a real lens
diffusing through actual film it's also
the same way they did the lasers so that
takes us to the phantom menace how do
you guys think that the vice savers of
the phantom match
uh i think they must have went frame by
frame like kind of that's when they had
computers i'm guessing right
the matrix came out the lightsabers and
the prequels are about as basic as they
come when it comes to visual effects
they used to be incredibly difficult and
now they're quite possibly the easiest
vfx shot you can do but in the early
days of digital vfx lightsabers were
super monotonous task because you'd have
to be in photoshop or something and
you'd have to do it with shape layers
and masks and go through and you'd have
to move all four corners of this
rectangular mask frame by frame by frame
by frame and you would have to actually
calculate in the motion blur that's
something people don't really realize
about lightsabers is when you swing them
you don't get a blade you end up with a
giant fan but thanks to video copilot
sabre which is a free plugin for after
effects lightsabers have never been
easier the lightsabers the prequels are
very plain compared to like what
lightsabers look like in current movies
and what they look like back in the old
movies it's a great way of getting it
done you know it's a glowing rod for
sure but you lose that on a bunch of
flicker and a bunch of form and also
because the glow is all done in post you
don't get the really crazy organic blur
that you get from actual light effects
like it's not actually passing through
lenses
then if we go and look at the most
current version
now you're getting disney money put into
your life
it's no longer a two-dimensional effect
you're actually getting 3d tracked
shapes with like you know fuzzes on the
edge there's shape and dimension there
and another interesting effect is that
motion blur motion blurring an object is
like lowering the exposure on it the
faster something moves the less time it
has to shoot photons from the position
it's in so if you have a really bright
light and you streak the light really
fast you're going to get a dimmer streak
than as if you just kept the light in
one spot now back in the day when they
have lightsabers and they're swinging
them around it's just one white wash
right the exposure doesn't change at all
but if you look at the lightsabers from
the new star wars films you notice that
the tips this the color starts coming
down the white starts to go away and you
start to get color coming in at the tip
of the lightsaber whereas the center
starts to stay stays really glowy you
know simulation is trying to basically
act
like what would happen if we actually
filmed the surreal what are all the
steps that would happen to those photons
on their way to the camera there's one
other thing that they're doing and
this is subtle because we live in the
future and we've invented leds which did
not exist back when they filmed the
original star wars we can now put lights
in the lightsaber props and so we have
lightsabers that actually cast light on
the talent in all the other star wars
films except for maybe some of the
prequels you don't have that they
couldn't do anything like that they'd
have to draw it in by hand or you know
simulate it so knowing what you guys do
about this process now and all these
different ways you can make lightsabers
i'll pose you a question
how would you make
a brown lightsaber george lucas is like
look it's my dying wish to have a brown
lightsaber in star wars and it has to
look good and you're like uh the brown's
kind of a darker color and he's like
yeah
figure it out what do you do we should
just shine some lights in front of some
turds and see what happens
[Music]
so because the problem that you have to
deal with when you start getting into
weird colors is that like a the core of
the lightsaber might not necessarily be
white and the only reason it's white is
because it's so bright that the camera
can't expose it like in reality you
should be able to expose the camera down
and the core would actually just become
the color of the lightsaber how do you
glow something that's not a bright color
because a glow has to be a certain color
if i'm shining like a bright blue
flashlight and the light is so bright
that it's white well the fringe has to
be like a really saturated blue because
that's what's happening is you're
pulling down the exposure from that but
you can't like go to a like oh i'm
shining a bright brown light and then
the glow is brown
or a black light and the glow is black
what does a camouflage lightsaber look
like oh i want to find out what a camo
lightsaber looks like what does
a bacon lightsaber look like are we
going to do a lightsaber with like a
bunch of bacon like wrapped
around to make a lightsaber a big like a
bacon dog situation or is it the bacon
itself that's the problem we're going to
try to solve with this video and try to
do lightsaber colors that you've never
seen before
tactical olive green jet black blaze
orange for hunting safety woodland camo
tactical tan leather what i'm talking
about is light sabers for men i use like
nice little
boys paddle wands real men don't carry
red light savers my reddish is dark pink
and pink is for little girls this video
which we're going to shoot tomorrow is
basically imagine like you know those
like soap for men commercials that you
see
they're still using whatever bar their
mommy bought for her little man it's
basically the same deal super obnoxious
so this is the same vibe so it starts
honestly that's so it
that's great
i'm talking about natural nourishing
cold-pressed hand-cut
more
while the team's shooting the manliest
lightsaber video ever me and nick wanted
to have a manly day of ourselves which
is why we're excited to talk about
today's sponsor bespoke post they sent
us a bunch of like camping and outdoor
gear chris and i are like guess what we
have some acreage out back let's go
utilize it look if you're a guy or a
girl who loves outdoors and camping or
even just very high quality items
bespoke post is probably the best
service for you christian and i are
actual natty subscribers to this service
we have been for almost a year now i
love all the products they send us every
single month every month they send you a
box full of gear you basically just fill
out a preference quiz at the beginning
of it and they give you a cool lineup of
constantly changing items every month
you have some say in what you get like
if you don't like the box they select
for you based on your interests you can
swap it out for another one you like and
there's a bunch to choose from to help
out during covet 19 they've purchased 53
million of products just from small
businesses they're really committed to
supporting lesser-known small businesses
right here in the u.s that existed
before the pandemic and will continue
well after today they hooked us up with
a bunch of outdoors gear check it out a
nice little tackle box it's like a
waterproof box surviving the great
outdoors because there's stuff like the
wires dude let's test this out let's cut
a piece of wood
oh
oh wow look at that
there's also this concentrate box that
they sent us comes with a coffee bean
tray
a coffee mug all made out of
concrete and if you want some coffee you
can brew it in this primula cold brew
coffee brewing kit this all comes in one
box as if they didn't hook us up with
enough stuff they sent us the grill kit
my friends call me the grill master
because on the weekends i like to grill
it up it comes with this nice kitchen
towel this is a nice oil spreader but
the main ingredient here these fun
little kebab grillers slam it down
kebabs being made if you're a big grill
guy the grill kids got everything you
need in all realness bespoke is super
easy to use every box has at least
seventy dollars in retail value but it
only costs forty five dollars a month so
to get twenty percent off your first box
go to bspk dot me slash corridor crew 20
or click the link in the description
below and enter corridor crew 20 at
checkout to get 20 on
[Music]
the great outdoors
i hate l.a
look at this look at this oh
sorry like this place
my character motivation is that i'm very
insecure someone made fun of my purple
lightsaber and so i started this company
to prove to them
that i'm not a [ __ ]
just slap a lens on potato and let's get
this shoot started real men don't give a
[ __ ] about camera settings
all right you guys set yeah
hey man listen up are you tired of these
[ __ ] ass lightsaber colors like baby
blue and purple
look at these lightsabers when i was a
young child i bought a purple lightsaber
and everyone made fun of me for years to
the point where i had to leave school
and i was expelled i went to great
depression and i started this company
i won't stop making bad jokes until one
of them is good cut
okay okay we got deluxe models our
lightsabers are two inches longer and
extra girthy for that thick slice my
visual picture artists are going to be
on overtime tonight
do you want to see how cool jd turns on
his lightsaber
and introducing our stealth saver it's
invisible
this one's invisible watch out it's very
very dangerous
okay cool guys that's a wrap
that's a wrap
[Music]
so we've explained to you how they did
all different style lightsaber effects
what about something like impossible
like a black lightsaber right now i'm
sure you've heard of like a dark saber
or the black lightsabers um you know
it's a common thing in the fringe star
wars canon to make a black lightsaber is
going to require us to do a very
different technique than how they've
done lightsaber effects in order to have
darkness you must have light in order to
have peace you must have war
so in order to make this black
lightsaber feel dark i need to actually
have a glowing fringe around the outside
that's very subtly raising the
brightness around it so that that
darkness feels extra dark so i can go
through and little by little i can add
these dark fringes now the thing that
makes this special it's not just your
average black fuzz i'm gonna put on a
mode called soft light it's going to
take the colors underneath it's going to
raise their saturation as it lowers the
brightness it's a pretty cool effect and
it really gives this feeling of like a
burned film that feels like it's sucking
the light out about that white halo we
were talking about well i actually have
that here and it raises the brightness
around that dark saber to make the
darksaber feel darker and that's how i
made a shadowsaver a charcoal black
lightsaber as a manly sam would say
today i'm doing the camo saber when you
think of a camo lightsaber at first it's
like oh well it's just a lightsaber with
camo patterns right it's easy when you
actually sit down and try to do it the
issue that you immediately are faced
with is the fact that camo is not a
bright pattern and inherently a
lightsaber is a very bright source of
light it's a very hot object we have to
right away sell the audience on the fact
this is a camo saver we started off with
this simple camo pattern here it's a
jpeg that i got on the internet thank
you the internet i started with a simple
wave warp so that it kind of gives it a
little bit of like a free flowing fluid
motion to it the thing is lightsabers
are cylindrical so the next step cc
cylinder i gave it a slight rotation so
that it kind of looks like it's swirling
we have this camo pattern that swirls
around a stick that doesn't look like a
lightsaber that just looks like a tube
of like camo wrapping paper we needed to
make this look like energy like there's
an energy source i did a very simple
luma mat onto our sabre plug-in which
we've been using liberally throughout
this project so the saber gives us these
nice edges this sort of like energy
emitting edge that's all well and good
but still kind of looks like a hot butt
trash how do we make this glow well you
just pre-comp all this stuff you bring
it into our main comp here and then
we're just like stacking glow layers
behind this uh this main source of uh
our camo pattern and yeah i think we
have an effect here that sells as camo
right away while also feeling like a
lightsaber at the same time i think i
think we've done it we finally made a
camo lightsaber so what nico asked me to
do actually is uh he asked me to make a
lightsaber with hair on it i'm not too
sure why but that's kind of what visual
effects is you just kind of do stuff
your total tubes the hilt is the normal
hilt but then it's just a bear pelt
pretty much the first thing i did was i
modeled like a rough lightsaber kind of
thing and i just like hand tracked it to
match the movement of the red lightsaber
as best i can and then from the cylinder
i can just spawn hair so i spawned some
more like clunky like chunky kind of
hair and then i had another pass of just
like more loose kind of hair on the top
and this this kind of makes an overall
like layered hair instead of just one
kind of like uniform look to it octane
has these great like hair materials that
you can just kind of fool around with
and like make it so it's a little bit
more wet looking or like has different
color variations in between it so i was
able to make this like hair lightsaber
that just kind of wishes around and like
moves around when he moves this thing
it's got all dynamics and everything the
hardest thing i think was to light the
scene because when we filmed sam here
you can see that he's like half of them
is lit and then half of them has got
like light like reaching through kind of
like light through a tree kind of thing
and like to light it i was able to use
like an octane light and then like have
a texture in it and then it like
projects like patches of light and then
it also keeps it in shadows the hot
spots are what make this like stand out
that much more pretty much turned out
amazing in my opinion the second one
nika wanted me to do a bacon lightsaber
i found a texture online of just a long
bacon strip and then from there i was
just able to add some bones to it and
just add like a simple dynamic scent to
the bones you track it to the lightsaber
and then just pull around with the
dynamics it just has the initial wiggle
and then it folds onto itself and that's
how i got the bacon to look the most
realistic in my opinion there's some
other really funny weird lightsabers i
have a call of duty brown aka desert tan
blaze orange we have a chrome lightsaber
we have a gun that's actually a
lightsaber and don't forget you can see
all these lightsabers you can see this
whole video on the quarter channel
youtube.com corridor it's out right now
let's go watch it we haven't put a video
on corridor in like a year so i was like
oh i didn't know they have a main
channel
[Laughter]
corridor still around it's still kicking
josh has an instagram called just josh
and it is super cool josh has been
learning how to use a bunch of really
advanced programs like houdini to do
really cool little visual effects magic
tricks you should definitely check out
his instagram all the link down in the
description below